I remember hearing that you were
originally supposed to be in the cast of
the five floats which I watched this
weekend it was wonderful and I was
curious like can you can you reveal
which role was supposed to be the one
you were playing I would have played
Eddie that he's the gentleman that that
I believe he steps on a mind and gets
blown up haven't seen the film yet but I
would have played that that particular
character and I was looking forward to
that film not only because I just love
and adore Spike Lee the messages that he
creates in his films that are so
powerful and strong and but also because
the cast he was talking to at that time
it was me and samuel l.jackson and
pencil Washington and Denzel Sun it
didn't work out for any of us because
the song got pushed and and Spike I was
wanting everyone to be there the whole
time
overseas when he shot it I was still
shooting better call Saul
and had was juggling that with godfather
of Harlem so it didn't work out we were
even announced to do it and it was just
so hard for me not to be able to do that
film I'm looking forward to seeing it
this week and I know I enjoyed the
script it was interesting spike scripts
contains so much but it felt so much
like a cross between the sierra madre
you know the treasure of sierra madre
and and also the whole idea of never
leaving a man behind that they all were
back for someone that was left behind if
they loved their respected but yeah I
hope to work with spike again soon I
love what he does you know I feel like
he's you know always just so engaging
he takes chances which i think is just
so courageous even if their chances that
you don't agree with he takes those
chances and those risks and creates
something really different from them and
its really been lovely to know him all
these years
watch his filmmaking progress and grow
and deepen and have a deeper
and more profound statement in a more
subtle way he's he's just brilliant at
what he does and so I look forward to
seeing this movie he's always so
committed to making the film a film and
also a movie
absolutely he's committed to telling a
story and he draws that commitment is
drawn from his understanding of the time
he grew up in and so I'm really anxious
to see the five Bloods because to see
how it it translated from paper to film
because that's the time I grew up in as
well you know we're close in age so his
view is is you know look his brilliance
is not lost on me at all and it affects
me deeply because last week I was
watching a particular piece of news feed
earlier in the day I saw a piece earlier
in the day maybe it was 11 or 12 where
the police were on the roof of the
minnesota police department and they
were putting up some very shabby
barricades on the roof I scratched my
head and when everything was peaceful
they're looking down at the crowd of all
that later on that night that very same
angle of that police station was the
exact same angle but the police station
was now burning all the police left the
station this is a Minnesota after George
Florida and I and I'm hearing the chant
no justice no peace no justice peace and
I'm watching the fire and I just went I
grant my heart it took me right back to
burning down south and do the right
thing and that's when I went you know
Spike Lee then was way ahead of this
time and it's reflected of our time now
and I got choked up and started to cry
and turn my news feed off on my phone
because that moment I lived that in
shooting I lived that in my life I mean
the Getty square white riots of 1964 65
in Yonkers New York or race riots I was
there as the kids the babysitter brought
me out there you know I just I've lived
through so many of these moments and to
see that and go okay do the right thing
okay what here is that okay ito and
footage I'm watching the what year is it
now that's 2020 you know and we were
back in 1999 you know it's like wow and
that's when I got a little sad but a
little happy because an artist that I
know and love
so committed to what he does and the
true mark and test of time in all of his
films
he's been do the right thing this is the
movie that still holds up today and his
being look then it's being looked at
more crisp on Connors mom it teaches the
film class and she was showing do the
right thing last week it was just shown
in in the Netherlands and Holland had a
major theater like people are revisiting
this movie so you know it tells you
that's a mark of a genius filmmaker and
I I wish spike continued to success in
that realm because it's a bigger picture
of the work that he does in his life to
make a film that affects us on a level
that carries through time my sadness
came around nothing's changed that oh
this time something has to change and
you know and so I'm hopeful I'm hopeful
that it will the people now it's become
a world movement and when that happens
then change starts to really people are
now relating especially New Zealand like
I know we're in a world of black and
white but when you go to like New
Zealand and they're honoring George
Floyd but also honoring their Aboriginal
people who have been discriminated
against it's a beautiful thing that
means everyone's relating to you know
rejecting anger and force and fear and
racism the whole world is and they're
taking it on as their plight because
little do we know that most people
whether you're white even if you like
have probably experienced some of the
same things as well so gender inequality
you know what I'm hoping it's gonna
bring us back to back because women have
suffered more than anybody you know over
the longest periods of time as well
because no one looks at their plight you
know it's like they're not black they
have white privilege such a horrible
horrible label because because we I
don't know your life I don't know where
you you grew up like when I work with
Boaz your key another wonderful
filmmaker incredible artist Jewish boy I
grew up on a kibbutz raised in Brooklyn
did a black movie made a movie about
black people and people try to attack
him on it I went well you don't know his
life let me just tell you about his life
so he doesn't have to tell you himself
and doesn't look arrogant or a displaced
he you know this was his life he grew up
here with us and he's got a hell of a
basketball game if you you know want to
clock that and check that office being
black but his voice is that of humanity
and isn't that what we're trying to get
back to isn't that what the whole world
wants us to acknowledge being human and
humanity says okay look you and I are
going to get together peacefully and go
and March you know we don't we have a
right to do that and it's inhuman to
disallow that it's inhuman to co-opt
that that happened and that everything
rose to another beautiful spiritual
level in our world because then the
world got involved and said I can relate
to that I can relate to that this
happened here this happened in our
culture and then we could become human
again and I think that's what we're
really we're really looking for and
we're demanding of our legislators our
government our leaders to have that
humanity that guides us
my biggest sadness besides what's going
on the worlds that we have no real
leadership and we need that and I as an
actor need bad
I need a fearless director either
director myself
fearless producer to guide us to a place
where we have entertainment that fosters
our compassion and our humanity and I
think it's coming